hey what's up guys I'm kitty HD here and
for a while I used to always carry my
smartphone in one pocket and my pocket
camera the Sony rx100 in the other just
because the image quality is that much
better and recently I had the sony QX
lenses come in and i'll be detailing my
experiences with those very shortly on
video but honestly in a world where the
best camera you have is just the one you
have with you
smartphone cameras have been getting
really good recently maybe not good
enough to replace your point-and-shoot
but good enough to make you think twice
about taking it with you so this list
might be totally different in three
months or something at the rate
technology is moving nowadays but this
is my totally unscientific and totally
unofficial list of the top five cameras
that also happen to make phone calls
there are four categories to my totally
unscientific test number one is
sharpness and detail number two is color
accuracy slash dynamic range
number three is video and number four is
control so getting right into it at
number five is the Samsung Galaxy s4
it's obviously not the newest one we're
going to talk about here but it's no
slouch it's one of the most popular
Android phones out there today it has a
13 megapixel sensor and it's rocking an
F 2.2 aperture it does not have optical
image stabilization but then again most
smartphones don't have oh is but it does
have it digitally but more importantly
it has an incredible software suite
Samsung's camera features let you change
a ton of different things while shooting
you get all these live filters you get
the burst mode to get HDR and you get
all the different camera modes
essentially that let you choose what
sort of shooting experience you want and
in fact I think this is the best
smartphone camera experience when it
first came out when it was first
available it was easily blowing away
every other smartphone out there on my
scale the galaxy s4 gets an 8 for
sharpest in detail thanks to that 13
megapixel sensor and the image
processing it gets a 7 for colors on
dynamic range just because it tends to
over saturate the colors a little bit a
little bit too much where it looks maybe
more pleasing to the real eye but a
little bit less accurate than it should
in real life it gets an 8 for video
because the 1080p 30 frames per second
video looks stellar it might not have
optical image stabilization like we said
which would make it a little bit
smoother and less shaky but overall you
can also take
pictures while you're recording it's got
a whole bunch of video features that you
can use so it gets a pretty solid video
score it gets a nine four controls
because like we said that's its
specialty it has an incredible software
suite with a whole bunch of different
controls over the shooting experience
with all the different modes you get and
it might be a little bit difficult to
use it first which is why I gets a point
off because it's a little bit spread out
and has this weird menu on the top left
corner where it also has a menu when you
hit the menu button so it's a little bit
too spread out but you'll get to learn
it and it has a 5-inch 1080p viewfinder
that makes it spacious enough to enjoy
the shooting experience overall that
brings it to a total score of 32 so
coming in at number four is the LG g2
which is often seen as a direct
competitor to the galaxy s4 nowadays so
one of the prettier phones that have
been released recently I mean that bezel
have you seen it it's pretty sweet and
it's also rocking a 13 megapixel sensor
with optical image stabilization and I
don't know if people realize how rare
actual optical image stabilization is
inside of the smart phones we have today
because of how thin and small the
smartphones were making are but it's
pretty impressive when they actually
pull it off and LG's been working really
hard on their cameras especially we see
the improvement from the lg optimus G
camera a year ago the g2 scores an 8 for
sharpness and detail thanks to the 13
megapixel sensor and optical image
stabilization it gets a 7 for color
accuracy and dynamic range because it
tends to actually understand I need bit
but it also has decent dynamic range and
it gets a 9 for video thanks to that
1080p 30 frames per second recording and
image stabilization with smooth out
video a lot and it also has a great mic
a lot of people don't realize that and
it gets an 8 for the slightly less
intuitive but still full of features
control maybe you could use a little
organizational update through a software
update but it's pretty good so
flip-flops the last two scores of the
galaxy s4 and ends up with that score
again of 32 so number 3 is the very new
iPhone 5s and iPhones as long as we know
them have always been hailed as
brilliant camera smartphone performers
and this new iPhone is no exception and
it's actually an improvement over last
year's iPhone 5 still has an 8 megapixel
sensor same as last iPhone but this new
sensor is a little bit bigger so it's
going to give you bigger pixels which is
going to give you better dynamic range
and better low-light performance and
it's also rocking an F 2.2 aperture with
the new lens so it's going to give you
even better low-light performance but
what's neat about the new iPhone which
is a little trick it has
a new dual tone flash on the back so it
has a white flash and an amber LED flash
and it'll basically evaluate the scene
and determine which amount of each flash
it needs to flash to get the most
accurate colors and skintone
representation so it's a neat trick so
the new iPhone grabs an 8 for sharpness
and detail thanks to the new sensor and
excellent image processing it gets a 9
for accurate colors on dynamic range
plus it kind of can cheat a little bit
because the HDR button is right there in
the viewfinder at all times which no
other phone on this list has readily
accessible so if you really want to turn
on HDR it's always there and I found it
to have some of the best color
representation of any phone that I take
pictures with it also gets a 9 for video
because not only is a 1080p video pretty
good it also has a 720p 120 frames per
second recording mode where you can
basically slow it down and get super
slow-motion footage of maybe action
footage or whatever else you want to
shoot in super slow motion that you
wouldn't ordinarily get again it doesn't
have optical image stabilization which
is why it's losing a point and it can be
a little bit shaky at times but it does
look pretty sweet and it finishes with
an 8 for control because honestly you
don't get all that much control for the
iPhone but what you do get control over
is very simple very easy to use
intuitive and just always works the HDR
is also some of the best I've seen again
in any phone because it doesn't over
process or over exaggerate the lows or
the highs that it's bringing in so it's
a pretty good pretty good camera that
totals out to give the iPhone 5s a score
of 34 so number 2 is the beast
it's the Nokia Lumia 1020 probably best
known for its camera and this is going
to be easily the most favorite choice
most popular choice among people who are
used to using higher end cameras and
DSLRs and things like that
Lumia 1020 has a 41 megapixel sensor a
41 megapixel sensor behind some
beautiful F 2.2 aperture Carl Zeiss
glass a real xenon flash instead of just
LED lights turning on and off and has a
focus assist light and has the largest
sensor physically of any of the other
smartphones on this list which means
it's going to get excellent low light
performance and very shallow depth of
field which is unusual for a smartphone
the 1020 does have its faults though
mostly in the image processing I found
the biggest problems I had with it to be
in the color representation I
consistently got strange colors you know
y'all been taking ten shots with the
Lumia 1020 and seven of them will be
beautiful perfect shots you wouldn't
expect to ever get that out of a
smartphone and then three of them will
just look awful because of their the
color and the the image processing so if
I had any problem with the Lumia 1020
it's how it processed the photos that it
took with that incredible lens and
sensor so it's a 10 for sharpness in
detail I mean come on it's 41 megapixels
and even the oversampled 5 megapixel
shareable shots that it gives you are
extremely sharp so that's useful and
plus you can crop down those 41
megapixel sensors for lossless zoom and
you end up getting like some really
sweet shots even if you didn't intend to
take them from that far away colors and
dynamic range score is a seven just
because of the slight color shifts and
frequent processing problems I had with
color accuracy the video score only
drops a point and it gets a nine because
it's pretty much gorgeous video you have
a very large sensor for the shallow
depth of field you didn't get a very
close minimum focusing distance so
sometimes you tap to focus and it
wouldn't focus on what you wanted it to
but you get optical image stabilization
so it's smooth video the microphone is
pretty good just the colors a little bit
off and the control score is a nine the
pro cam app from Nokia is one of the
most powerful versatile camera apps in
any smartphone period to this date it
gives you full control manual control if
you want over every single aspect of the
phone even manual focusing if you want
it now the one point off of it is really
nitpicking like there's no built-in HDR
it can only take bracketing that you'd
have to bring into Photoshop to make an
HDI yourself and there's other little
things like that like the viewfinder is
only 720p but overall it's an excellent
application plus you get the ability to
crop with lossless no loss of detail
afterwards which is kind of just icing
on the cake that gives the Lumia 1020 a
total score of 35 so that brings us to
the number one camera on a smartphone
which on this scale belongs to the
samsung galaxy note 3 those may be a
little bit confusing at first because on
paper that should be very close to the
galaxy s4 but when you look deeper into
it you'll see that the performance and
the experience increases you get out of
using the note 3 are very crucial it is
indeed rocking a 13 megapixel sensor and
an F 2.2 aperture just like the galaxy
s4 it might even be the exact same
hardware but the image processing is
different I found the
to actually be a bit better the galaxy
s4 sort of tends to overexpose just a
little bit the noise reduction was also
a bit less aggressive and there was also
more sharpening done so the photos
looked more sharp more crisp more clean
so the sharpness and detail score is a
nine this thing takes incredible
highlight photos like outdoor photos and
regular light photos it looks just
gorgeous on any display for colors and
dynamic range this grabs the 8 the same
as the galaxy s4 did for slightly over
saturated colors that look a little bit
more vivid than real life but yet still
are not too crazy that they're
unappealing to the eye for video this
thing is an animal now it already takes
great 1080p video but instead of the
iPhone super slo-mo trick the note 3
takes 4k video it takes ultra-high
definition 4k video a lot of people
don't realize the versatility of 4k
video is the same as the versatility of
a 41 megapixel photo obviously no one
has a 41 megapixel monitor to appreciate
the Lumia 1020 s photos in their full
glorious resolution but you can still
appreciate them as being sharper and
more detailed on no matter what display
are looking at then your traditional
photo plus you have the ability to crop
down and keep a lot of that detail and
make a better looking photo out of a
portion of the huge photo you took that
same advantage comes to 4k so most
people really usually don't have 4k
displays although some people do but you
can actually see the difference between
a 4k video and a 1080p video on a
display like that at 2560 by 1600
display but more importantly you can
actually crop down and use 4k video in
just a portion of that for a 1080p clip
which I've actually done on the note 3
looks really impressive the same way you
would crop down a 41 megapixel shot to
get what you want in the frame you can
do exactly that with the note 3's 4k
video to make a great-looking 1080p
video so all this would earn it a 10 but
it doesn't have optical image
stabilization so it gets it a night and
in the control Department it also is
very similar to the galaxy s4 software
and it gets a 9 although there are some
nice improvements like you get a much
larger 5.7 inch viewfinder and you also
get a better performance and more RAM
for the longer burst shots but what's
weird is they actually removed the night
mode and included a golf mode
someone want to explain that it's a
little weird but yeah gets a 9 so that
gives a node 3 and overall total
slightly more balanced total score of 35
so why the node 3 over the Lumia 1020
despite the same score honestly it's
just a little more well rounded and that
makes a better package a lot of people
don't realize the versatility of 4k
video and as a video person you're doing
videos on YouTube a kind of internally
weighted video a little bit more but at
the end of the day it's your money being
spent what's your number one what's your
number one smartphone camera I will have
links to everything I've talked about in
this video all the smart phones right
below that like button so if you want to
hit that up but those were all be there
but also I'll also have all the full
reviews of all the smart phones I talked
about and then I'll include some
honorable mentions because there are
some smart phone cameras that were in
the top 5 that are still great even
though they didn't make the list so I'll
include those below as well either way
that's been it thank you for watching
this video be sure to subscribe if you
want to see more videos like this coming
out very soon and that's it I'll talk to
you guys in the next one